30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes
10 minute mindfulness ready to become
get feel on the app store or google play
hey guys
this is your summer shred challenge so
this
is a 5 four three two
one challenge so what do i mean so you
will be combining both
heat cardio as well as strength training
five minutes of cardio
four minutes of lower body strength
training three minutes of
upper body strength two minutes of core
and we will end with one minute of plank
so it is a solid 15 minute
summer shred challenge okay once you
start this workout
there will be minimal rest in between so
let's get your body ready
and let's complete this challenge
[Music]
together
[Music]
so let's get your body warmed up okay
let's start by jogging on the spot
the first five minutes is going to be a
hit cardio
so we want to really get all your
muscles warm up
the blood flowing and really get your
joints ready okay
so start by jogging on the spot and
slowly
raise your heels up and start
to touch your butt okay so
kickbacks really just loosen up the
joints
shake your shoulders relax your upper
body
and just give me few shoulder rolls all
right
good now get into
jumping jacks let's go
nice jumping jacks keep your arms
straight
with the elbows slightly bent step out
and step in so the goal here throughout
the
challenge is to pace your breathing okay
so remember to breathe in and out pace
your breathing
take deep long breaths
good and now just jog
and let's slow it down and now let's get
into some
squats push your butt back forward
butt back and forward okay so squat back
up squeeze squat back and squeeze
now squat with a reverse
lunge squat and change
leg so remember with reverse lunges
try to get your knees to tap the floor
and keep them bent to a 90 degree
back squat and
back good step right at the edge of your
mat
let's get into inchworm feel the stretch
on your hamstrings
and one push up okay
and now up back down
into one one push-up if you want to
you can also get onto your knees
slowly down feel the stretch on your
hamstrings
nice solid plank push up and slowly
push yourself back up all right
get into standing and now just rotate
side to side your heart rate should be
slightly elevated right now you should
feel slightly warm
okay just slowly twist side to side
and the first five minutes it's going to
be explosive
movement okay so the first move is going
to be
double jacks get down into a sprawl get
your chest
to touch the floor and jump back up
into jacks all right the second move
is going to be a side shuffle
okay so those are the first two moves
are we ready
let's go double jacks sprung chest down
up jacks remember chest
touch the floor push back up
okay so breathing
let's drive your heart rate up back down
strong legs strong heart high energy
to kick off this challenge
remember only 15 sec
15 minutes so i want to see
your best let's go
down chest tap up
give me one more okay get back up jacks
sprawl and back up
okay good job side to side shuffle okay
so start right at the edge of the mat
double tap
double and tap are we ready stay
low stay light on your feet
keep going remember push your butt back
get into a squat okay
do not bend or hunch down get into a
squat
push good job
keep breathing let's just adjust that
tap and reach if you have a small space
you can just go once tap once
and tap okay so choose your option
my thighs are on fire let's keep going
last one more back
and up oh my gosh okay
now let's get down onto the floor start
at the edge of your mat we're going to
get into
lateral bare cross okay so start on all
fours
crawl to the edge of your mat and crawl
back
remember to keep your back flat do not
pike
your butt up back flat and
crawl good job keep going
i know i can feel the burn paste it out
good job left and right
left and right halfway there
stay strong brace your core
i told you this is a high energy workout
high energy challenge last one
and drop back down okay
get back up working on your inner and
outer thighs in and out squat jump
jump out tap down in and tap
okay nice and easy find your pace
compete with yourself all right
that is your goal you're your own
competition
so keep pushing it if this is too much
take a step in take a step out but don't
stop okay i want you to keep moving
throughout the entire challenge
once you're ready join me back
tap touchdown remember push your butt
back tap
you have one final exercise
right after this tap
reach good that's one more
and up oh my gosh
oh my heart rate is going 170 bpm right
now
okay final workout plank jacks
okay with mountain climber
two plank jacks two
climbers so remember brace your core
keep your back flat do not pike your
butt up
drive your knees in towards your elbows
okay
push into the ground keep your neck
neutral
check it out
stay with me you're gonna get a short
break
right after this round
that's 10 seconds let's go two more
last one more oh my
gosh okay all right don't stop
get back up okay come up right now
take a short break 40 seconds break
keep yourself hydrated if you need to
and
the next four minutes is going to be a
lower
body strength second all right
[Music]
okay first exercise new
to a squat okay it's going to be a full
squat
so start in a kneading position push up
into a squat get back down push
up into a squat i want you to really
carry your own body weight and drive up
into
a squat okay push up
and stand tall so remember this is
a lower body workout so drive from your
lower body
and push up good job
now leading with the opposite leg
up down
push through your heels okay right leg
push get back down and up
brace your coal core at all times
keep your upper up upper body upright
i am struggling to talk all right good
job
okay next workout it's going to be a
lunge
with a reverse kickback alright so
start with your right leg forward left
leg back reverse lunge
squeeze your glutes as you come up down
squeeze nice and controlled okay
this is a strength circuit so do not
rush
final balance squeeze good job
down squeeze
breathe out as you come up squeeze
one more and change the other side okay
now switch side
right leg back up squeeze
back down squeeze feel that contraction
hold it for one count before you lower
your leg
back down up squeeze
down and squeeze few more raise your
core
stay strong up and
shake it out okay remember our warm up
squat to reverse lunges that's what
we're going to do
right now okay so get into a squat
left leg back squat low
right leg back squat
and left good alternating between legs
good job keep your stuns shoulder width
apart okay so front view
squat push back
squat and back good job
there you go
remember always keep keep your body
upright
do not hunch forward if you're doing
this this is wrong okay
body upright squat push back
squat and lunge back your legs
should be almost dead right now okay
and that's the kind of feeling we want
oh my gosh okay
final workout curtsy to
a side lunge okay so start right at the
edge of your mat
get into a curtsy step out straighten
your leg curtsy push
through your heels curtsy and
push feel the stretch on your inner
thighs feel the works
on your outer glutes okay lunge back
push lunge back
push good job now change side okay go
curtsy
step push good job
so remember toes pointed
forward cross your leg behind but don't
cross it
too far okay making sure that your body
is still
facing forward cross
step push
and step oh my gosh guess what guys
you're done with the second round four
minutes of
lower body workout take a short break
if you need to if you need to pause this
video pause this video right now the
next
is going to be a three minute upper body
circuit okay strong arms sexy shoulders
let's do it
[Music]
we're going to be working on our mat the
first workout is going to be a staggered
push-up
choose your option okay if you want to
start from your knees left hand slightly
back
right hand forward stagger it and push
so you should feel the work more on
the front arm okay and the front chest
push
and up good job if you want to challenge
yourself then get up onto your toes
down push raise your core
solid plank do not dip push
one more push now change
left hand forward right hand back go
this is going to be more challenging up
down up good job whoo
feeling the burn on your left chest up
up good job five more seconds almost
there
that's one more up and just
rest okay i told you
short breaks okay next up down plank
wipe your sweat
ready let's go low plank push yourself
up
get back down push yourself up
and get back down so minimal movements
coming from your hips okay you got to
really suck the belly in
really engage your core and really
push using the strength of your arms
good job down push up
back down and up
burn strong shoulders
slowly place it back down
raise your core i know it's raining in
here
and back down let's shred
let's keep ourselves shredded ready for
summer
down and rest it out
okay all right final upper body workout
lie flat onto the ground this is going
to be
a superman with a back squeeze and
push yourself up into a plank so the
goal here is to squeeze your
legs push up in one unit
okay do not peel yourself off the floor
push up raise your core back
down so if you find yourself doing this
this is wrong this is not a strong plank
okay so up squeeze brace the cord tuck
your toes
up there you go lower yourself back down
straight body ready tuck
breathe out good job there you go
squeeze tuck your toes
very good a few more squeeze your legs
feel the work on the back tuck and
done can you see
how much i'm sweating i hope you're
feeling the same as well
well good news 543 is done
we have two minutes of cold work
and one minute of plank left okay so
just keep breathing throughout the
circuit all right
okay now let's start by lying down
on the mat all right the first workout
is going to be
full crunch so i want you to bend your
knees
in a 90 degree position reach your arms
up
okay now crunch up
extend your legs up and extend
only extend your legs as far as you can
without
arching your lower back so if you find
yourself
over extending and arching this is wrong
extend crunch up and extend
even if it's just a little bit the point
is that we want to be
engaging on our abs okay
not to hurt our lower back extend
crunch extend and
crunch good job full crunch full
extension
crunch all the way up tap your ankles
up good job
upper abs burning lower abs on
fire oh my god okay
i was waiting for that buzzer okay now
get
back up okay get into a scissor position
support your upper body now let's get
into
three flatter kicks and one knee tuck
okay
three flatter kicks one tuck and flutter
you're gonna really feel on your lower
abs you've done so much work
so this should be challenging
tuck flutter and
tuck drive your knees in towards your
chest
good job flatter
keep going
see that i'm not talking anymore because
it's really hurting
if you need to you can drop and rest
your heels and join me
back in the workout last few more five
seconds
one more in and
oh my gosh drop back down guys
we have one minute
of plank left you have come this far
with me
you have to hold this plane let's go
hold it
remember brace your core and just
keep a flat back this is wrong okay this
is not a plank
this is wrong as well brace your core
flat back keep your neck neutral gaze
onto the floor push into the ground push
your shoulders
away from you okay if you want an easier
option
you can spread your feet slightly wider
alright if you want to challenge
yourself then keep your feet
together this is going to engage your
core
even more the deep core muscles so brace
it
i know you don't want to be here right
now but you know what
you have only 15 seconds left so
you got to stay with me we are strong
last 10 seconds countdown
5 4 3
two one oh my
gosh it is raining
right here i'm drenched in sweat
okay so just get back up i don't want
you to stop moving right now
just shake it out okay
that was only 15 minutes but it's
intense
and because it's intense it's going to
really drive your heart rate up you're
going to start
burning calories not just during this
workout but even
after this workout okay your metabolism
is going to rise
for the next 24 hours and that's what we
want the afterburn
okay just paste it out and now
let let's just get down onto the floor
okay
step one leg back right leg forward and
just
push into the ground feel the stretch on
your hip flexor
and now just raise your arms
and breathe okay
really push in and breathe we have done
lots of work on our lower body
so take the time to stretch
all right and now straighten the front
leg i want you to feel the stretch on
your hamstring
i have tight hamstrings so just lower
yourself as much as you can and
really feel the stretch on your
hamstrings remember when you're
stretching
do not fight against it breathe into the
stretch
and slowly breathe out okay
breathe in deep in inhalation
and slow exhalation and hold it
good and now step back change leg
same thing push your body weight forward
feel the stretch on your right hip
flexor
and reach open up your heart open up
your chest
get the oxygen into your body
and breathe out straighten the front leg
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
and try to push yourself as far back as
you can
and just breathe
all right and now slowly get back up
this is one of my favorite stretches
what i want to do is step
slightly wider than shoulder width apart
link both arms together
and just really relax your upper body
okay
keep your leg straight relax your upper
body drop the weight and just swing
from left to the right so you will feel
the shift
of the weight going from left to right
and you will feel
your left and your right hand strings
being stretched out keep going
and now step wider just hold it
feel the stretch on the inner thighs
we're not rushing right now breathe in
and now slowly come back up
and now let's take three deep breaths
okay
breathe in and out
breathe in and out
one last one breathe in
and very
very well done that was a solid 20
minutes workout
for you to kick start your summer season
okay
so remember a short workout is better
than no
workout so get your workout routine
started right at home
if you need more workout videos do check
out my youtube channel
for a mixture of hit workouts strength
training
and even low impact workouts any types
of workout to suit
your need if you enjoy this video if you
are sweaty like me
then do give this video a thumbs up let
me know in the comments below how you're
feeling
and be sure to challenge yourself and
your friends
to complete this workout for a month
alright and share your progress with me
and i will see you in my next workout
all the best